The Walking Dead Daryl Dixon throws a
fan favorite character across an ocean
introduces a new Dynamic and leaves our
hero between a metaphorical rock and a
hard place here's what the ending of
season 1 means early on in The Walking
Dead Daryl Dixon Daryl manages to break
free from his capts and starts wandering
France searching for a way home running
into some new Walker variants and
meeting plenty of new characters along
the way where the original series
focused on Daryl's transformation from a
lone wolf survival list to a beloved
leader and a surrogate Father Figure to
RJ and Judith Grimes Daryl Dixon
explores this newfound empathy as Daryl
becomes a protector of a young boy named
laurant lant is a young boy who was born
via C-section after his mother had
already turned into a zombie and who is
now revered as the Messiah by a
religious Network called the union of
Hope members of the Union believe
laurance is destined to end the
apocalypse and restore Humanity to its
former glory if we're wrong at least you
will have helped a boy get to a better
place but if we're right why B on Hope
in a storyline that draws some parallels
to that of The Last of Us Daryl agrees
to transport this young savior across
France to the Union's base though in
episode five Daryl lant lon's father
Quinn and the nun Isabelle are captured
by agents of the Pua the episode ends on
a cliffhanger in which darl is forced
into a gladiator fight against the
enhanced Walkers created by the pooa
while some members of the Union sneak
into the puas arena to Stage A desperate
rescue attempt the finale of The Walking
Dead daral Dixon begins inside the
Gladiator pit where Daryl quickly
defeats a few of the ps's Genetically
Enhanced Walkers Quinn is sent in and
chained to Daryl to provide more of a
challenge though the pairs still managed
to defeat wave after wave of these new
and improved zombies their success draws
a surprising amount of support from the
crow Who start cheering Dixon as Daryl
and Quinn fight the enraged Provo leader
Jana decides to execute Daryl and Quinn
before things get out of hand but
they're saved by a well-timed bullet
which kicks off a full-blown uproar
inside the arena in the ensuing chaos
Daryl and Quinn Escape their chains and
Quinn reveals that he was infected
during the battle Quinn sacrifices
himself to make way for Daryl and the
Ron's Escape declaring his love for
Isabelle his former lover and the Ron's
biological Aunt who raised the rant in
Quinn's absence Daryl and his Union
allies rush to free Isabelle and Lan
from PUO custody though drawing the
final stage of their escape they come
face to face with the reanimated corpse
of Quinn in a heartbreaking turn of
events lant is forced to kill the Walker
who was once his father saving Isabelle
and later declaring it wasn't him
anymore and he was never my father with
Quinn put down for good the group
completes her escape from the arena and
splits up on the road faru and ail
depart into the woods while the rest
flee towards mon s Michelle along the
way Isabelle confesses to Daryl that she
invented a good deal of laon's Messianic
Powers hoping to impress Daryl and draw
support for the union oddly this brief
confession is jug deposed with a
roadside ambush from PIR agents by
Stefan kadron well L displays an eerie
level of persuasion that borders on the
supernatural lant imparts a message from
God and somehow convince his Cadron to
gun down his fellow agent allowing
Isabelle Daryl and lant to continue on
their way finally the trio arrives in
the Fortified city of mon San Michelle
where the religious Haven known as The
Nest resides the spal that he went
through to protect lant and deliver the
boy safely to the nest Daryl still has
his heart set on a return to America and
he departs in the night against Isabel's
protest after a brief stop in Normandy
Daryl boards a boat on Omaha Beach he is
about to set sail when he hears someone
calling his name and discovers that Lon
had followed him in order to say a
proper goodbye unfortunately his calls
also have attracted a fresh horde of
Walkers and thus the first season of
Daryl Dixon ends with a cliffhanger as
Daryl has to choose whether to set sail
or turn back to save lant despite being
a brutal murderer and a sworn enemy to
Daryl Dixon Stefan is visibly conflicted
when Jana gives in the orders to kill
the rant and his resolve crumbles when
faced with actually murdering the child
after returning to the Pu Hideout of
maon May Stefan attempts to lie his way
out of Jana's interrogation when he
returns without Al darl all
unfortunately for him she doesn't
believe any of it and orders her agents
to torture him for more information
while Daryl Dixon and his comrades may
have escaped the wrath of Jana for now
their fate now hinges on Stefan's
ability to withstand torture since he is
one of the few people who knows the
secret location of the nest consider
considering the gross levels of human
experimentation that Jana and the rest
of the Provo have demonstrated it's
unlikely that Stefan will be able to
hold out forever this perfectly sets up
the impending conflict between the nest
and the surviving members of the Pua
something that will likely be a major
focus in darl Dixon season
2 most exciting to some longtime fans
the episode's final moments reunite fans
with The Walking Dead stort Carol just
before the credits roll the episode Cuts
away to Free Port Maine where an unnamed
Drifter is seen riding Daryl's iconic
motorcycle the cyclist is pursued by
Carol and after a brief scuffle she
knocks him unconscious with a wrench she
interrogates him and discovers that he
bought the motorcycle from survivors
living further up the road and she locks
him in the trunk before riding off on
Daryl's motorcycle any Walking Dead F
will know that Carol and Daryl are
closer than perhaps any other characters
in the entire series and have been there
for each other through more than a
decade of strife and heartbreak despite
never pursuing a romantic relationship
they professed their love for each other
before darl left in the original series
finale now love has driven Carol to seek
out her friend after his disappearance
picking up the trail in Maine and
setting up a return for the next season
of The Walking Dead Daryl Dixon after
leaving their relationship up in the air
in the original series finale this
reunion could Herald a true happy ending
for both Daryl and Carol either way
we'll definitely be seeing more of her
the second season has been announced as
The Walking Dead Daryl Dixon the book of
Carol well much of Daryl Dixon season 1
centers around Daryl's survival and
desire to fight his way home to his
family the finale helps to clarify that
the series is also a very dysfunctional
fatherson Story one that is bugged down
by a long history of family trauma
sounds hard yeah it was when he was
around which was hardly ever throughout
both the original The Walking Dead
series and Daryl Dixon we learned that
Daryl's father was extremely abusive and
neglectful and that he was hardly ever
there for him or his brother Merl in a
rare moment of vulnerability darl tells
Isabelle that his grandfather had
neglected 's father as well and hints at
the generational trauma that has been
passed down through the Dixon family now
this trauma threatens the development of
another young boy lant to whom Daryl has
become a pseudo father figure the series
tells us as much during the final
confrontation between Quinn and lant
where Daryl encourages Lon to kill his
father's reanimated body and Lon disowns
his true father once and for all when
Daryl leaves in the middle of the night
Isabelle baldly calls him out for
repeating the cycle of fatherson
Abandonment that left him so
dysfunctional in the first Place thus
when lant arrives on the beach he forces
Daryl to finally confront the trauma
left behind by his father would Daryl
end up breaking the cycle and remaining
by Lauren's side as a real father figure
or he succumb to the same weakness that
caused his own substantial abandonment
issues although this season finale
places a heavy emphasis on Daryl Dixon's
attachment issues and his newfound
connection to lant some fans online
aren't too thrilled about this family
trauma storyline that the show was
thrust into Daryl's lab as pointed out
by many fans on Reddit darl do already
served as a surrogate father figure for
RJ and Judith Grimes essentially raising
both of them after Rick grimes's dis
appearance in season 9 this somewhat
invalidates Isabelle's argument about
repeating the cycle since staying in
France will be an act of Abandonment in
itself you think you're escaping history
by doing this but you are
not you're repeating it as such one
could argue that Daryl's abandonment
issues concern his true family rather
than his Newfound French allies to truly
conquer his history of family
dysfunction d will need to return to
America and resume his role as a father
figure to the Grimes children if this
explanation holds any weight it could
set up a very interesting Conflict for
season two of Daryl Dixon wherein lant
and his religious allies attempt to stop
Daryl from returning to where he
arguably truly belongs while the ending
of darl Dixon primarily serves as a
setup for the series forthcoming second
season it's important to clarify how the
season finale could tie into the rest of
the franchise as a whole because darl is
still in France at the end of the series
this finale also makes it extremely
unlikely that we'll see Daryl in the
upcoming Rick a Michonne spin-off
something that will no doubt disappoint
plenty of fans since his original goal
was to track down Rick Grimes on top of
that it's important to note that both
Negan and Maggie ree find themselves in
Manhattan in The Walking Dead dead City
if Daryl does Return To America it's not
out the question that we'll see him and
Carol overshoot their destination and
wind up further down the East Coast
potentially making a cameo in dead City
season 2 while some fans online were
entirely an enthus enthusiastic about
the way this finale put pressure on
Daryl Dixon to stay with lant showrunner
David zor says that he had planned this
ending from the start zel explained
during an interview with the rap that
was really my first pitch on the story
at that point he's not going to say it
because he's not that kind of guy he is
like I know I've got to do this this is
an obligation regardless of what I want
for myself I've got to do this thing zel
went on to say that this inner conflict
is hinted at earlier in the episode when
darl is trying to leave in the middle of
the night zel explained that nor re has
chose to play that scene with
demonstrative frustration angrily
throwing supplies into his bag because
he has torn on whether or not he should
really leave though this Cliffhanger
ending might not sit well with some fans
it's clear that both zel and Reedus
wanted to emphasize Daryl Dixon's in a
turmoil when he finally arrives on that
beach having discovered a new kind of
family and nearly abandoning them when
they need him most it's safe to say that
many fans were probably disappointed
when it was announced that the rumored
daral and Carol spin-off series will be
moving forward with only one of those
characters on top of the fact that they
are both fan favorite characters who
have been around since season 1 their
chemistry together is one of the
Undisputed highlights of the entire
series Daryl's solemn Journey overseas
through France feels a little bit lonely
when you remember he was supposed to be
accompanied by his best friend though
The Walking Dead primary director Greg
niiko says there was an unseen benefit
in removing her from season 1 he
explained during an interview with TV
Insider I think having the show
concentrate on Daryl specifically and
his experiences to lay the groundwork
for that then to bring Carol in later it
allows for richer storytelling it just
doesn't rely on two characters that you
already know because then there are less
places to go I think it allowed Daryl to
grow nicaro went on to explain that the
return of actress Melissa McBride in the
finale is also a boon for the series
since both McBride and Norman readers
will have a good deal of involvement
with the development of Carol and
Daryl's next chapter as for what that
next chapter will hold fans will just
have to wait until the book of Carol
drops in
[Music]